is the thief of joy
which is 100 like like because a lot of
times even in the manuscript we talk
about stuff like you can't really change
like we'll talk about like a guy being
short and how he can't get as many girls
but what are you going to do change your
height or like a woman's age like what
am i going to do get younger and i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be real so my last
boyfriend was
a short king and i was like it didn't
stop me from being in a relationship
with him but if i'm being honest i
wanted him to i wanted to talk a boy i
wanted to talk a boyfriend and i know
that's toxic masculinity and i know
that's all is it toxic it's not it's
your biology
it's like it's not toxic and that's what
like we we call these things toxic that
just are and we try to say like but
they're toxic to men because then short
men are like i'm not i'm not good enough
why yeah but like
you can't call it toxic when it's
biology it's just it's the same thing
with like
men being
turned off by fat girls yeah but so then
it is toxic to the individual
experiencing it so a fat girl is like i
feel unattractive i hate my life